thank you everybody who's wished me well
specifically thank you Warner Brothers
Sovereign pictures
Ed Pressman
Bobby Schroeder
Luciano lighting cameraman
people who made me look like that
Alan weisinger and Dick Smith thank you
my co-stars
Ron Silva
and Glenn
for finally persuading me to do it thank
you
Fred Specter and Hutton Sally Fisher
thank you also and some of you may
understand why
thank you David Cronenberg
and lastly if I may cut the call of a
telephone to London
where my wife is trying to keep a weight
and awake in a hotel bedroom
I wish you were here to help me carry
this because you helped me win it
thank you all